Mae's six years old, in first grade. And she's the kind of forthright kid who, when we sit down for an interview, before I can get to any of the things that I want to ask her, she launches into a few get-to-know-you questions of her own.
Mae今年六岁，上一年级。她是一个非常直率的孩子，当我们坐下来采访时，我还没来得及问我想问的问题，她就开始问我一些她想了解的问题了。
Hi, Mae.
嗨，Mae。
Uh, what's your favorite color?
嗯，你最喜欢的颜色是什么？
We discuss favorite colors. And then she moves on to--
我们讨论了最喜欢的颜色。然后她接着问——
What's your middle name?
你的中间名是什么？
I'm glad you're asking me that. My middle name is--
很高兴你问我这个。我的中间名是——
We move on to last names. And soon, she's instructed me on the pronunciation of her last name.
我们转而谈论姓氏。很快，她就开始教我怎么读她的姓了。
Can you say "Zmyou-jen-ski"? That's how you say it.
你会读“Zmyou-jen-ski”吗？那是正确的读法。
"Zmeel-jensky."
“Zmeel-jensky”。
[SNORTS] "Zmyou-jen-ski". Z-M-U-D-C-Z-Y-N-S-K-I.
[吸鼻涕声] “Zmyou-jen-ski”。Z-M-U-D-C-Z-Y-N-S-K-I。
The story I was there to talk to Miss "Zmyou-jen-ski" about happened this fall, at the beginning of the school year. In St. Louis, where she lives, it was hot out.
我这次去采访“Zmyou-jen-ski”小姐的故事发生在今年秋天，学年刚开始的时候。在她居住的圣路易斯，天气很热。
It's sort of a funny story. So my sister told me to wear long sleeves-- I mean, short sleeves, because it was, like, summer.
这算是一个有趣的故事。我姐姐让我穿长袖——我是说，短袖，因为当时就像夏天一样。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
So-- and I wanted to wear long sleeves, and I just got mad.
所以——我很想穿长袖，我就生气了。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I also said, stop bossing me around.
我还说，别对我指手画脚。
Though she really didn't like it, and she has a very fiery temper.
虽然她真的很不喜欢这样，而且她脾气非常火爆。
This is her older sister, Johanna. Johanna's eight, in third grade. Again, Mae's six, first grade. And Johanna, as the older sister, is very aware of the things that make Mae upset.
这是她的姐姐Johanna。Johanna八岁，上三年级。再说一次，Mae六岁，上一年级。作为姐姐，Johanna很清楚什么事情会让Mae心烦。
Mostly, when I tell her what to do.
通常是因为我告诉她该怎么做。
Especially, she says, when it comes to what Mae is wearing.
她说，尤其是在Mae穿什么衣服的问题上。
Like, she thinks fashion disasters are, like, the worst thing ever to happen. So she gets really angry when I tell her what to wear. And yeah, Mae gets very angry a lot. And her face turns red, and yeah.
比如，她觉得时尚灾难是有史以来最糟糕的事情。所以我告诉她穿什么时她会非常生气。是的，Mae经常非常生气。她的脸会变红，是的。
Here's Mae.
这是Mae。
I was, like, so frustrated. I had a big tantrum.
我当时，太沮丧了。我发了一顿大脾气。
What do you do when you have a tantrum?
你发脾气的时候会做什么？
I usually do this with my fist.
我通常会这样握紧拳头。
You're scrunching your fist as tight as they can go.
你把拳头攥得紧紧的。
Yeah. Mm-hmm. And I was, like, jumping and jumping and twitching my legs.
是的。嗯哼。我当时还在不停地蹦跳，双腿抽动。
Meanwhile, Mae and Johanna's mom, Megan, was trying to get them both dressed and ready for school.
与此同时，Mae和Johanna的妈妈Megan正试图帮她们穿好衣服，准备去上学。
And I just remember she was screaming, because I said, OK, Mae, you got to calm down so you can still get ready and get out the door. And she was just screaming that the only way she could calm down was if she punched her sister in the face.
我只记得她在尖叫，因为我说，好了，Mae，你得冷静下来，这样才能整理好出发。她一直尖叫说，唯一能让她冷静下来的方法就是打她姐姐的脸。
I told my mom, that's the only way for me to calm down.
我告诉妈妈，那是让我冷静下来的唯一方法。
And I said, well, that's not an option. So can you think of some other way to calm down? And then, I had to get ready, so I just left, and she was still kind of making quite a bit of noise. And then, when I came back, kind of miraculously, the tears had dried. She was smiling. Johanna was smiling.
我说，那是不可能的。所以你能想想其他冷静下来的方法吗？然后，我得准备一下，我就先走了，她当时还在闹腾。等我回来时，奇迹般地，眼泪干了。她在笑。Johanna也在笑。
What had happened? How did these two little kids work this out so quickly? Well, Mae and Johanna explained, it went down like this. Mae marched herself to Johanna's room and banged on the door. Johanna opened the door. And Mae has been working on not giving in to her anger, not taking the low road, but instead, using words, saying what she wants, which she did now.
发生了什么？这两个小家伙是怎么这么快解决问题的？嗯，Mae和Johanna解释说，事情是这样的。Mae走到Johanna的房间门口，用力敲门。Johanna打开了门。Mae一直在努力控制自己的脾气，不走极端，而是用言语表达自己的需求，她刚才就是这么做的。
I said, I want to punch you in the face, and that's the only way I can calm down.
我说，我想打你的脸，那是唯一能让我冷静下来的方法。
And then, Johanna, what did you say?
然后，Johanna，你说了什么？
Um, I want to kind of think about that.
嗯，我想考虑一下。
[IRA LAUGHS]
[IRA笑]
Um, you can punch me in the butt instead.
嗯，你可以打我的屁股。
This caught Mae off guard.
这让Mae措手不及。
I was like, OK. And then, I just tried it.
我心想，好吧。然后，我就试了试。
When you punched her butt, did you punch her like you were super mad? Or did you punch her kind of soft by then, because you were, sort of, half over it?
当你打她屁股的时候，你是真的很生气吗？还是说你那时候已经没那么气了，因为气消了一半？
I punched-- I punched it hard. Because, like-- so, like, to try to get all the anger out. Because if I punched it softly, it sort of-- it sort of only lets a couple pieces of the madness out of you.
我打——我用力打了。因为，就像——为了把所有的怒气都发泄出来。因为如果我轻轻地打，它只会——只会把体内的一点点怒火发泄出去。
And did it work? Did you get all the anger out?
有效吗？你把怒气都发泄出来了吗？
Yes, because I punched it super hard.
是的，因为我超级用力地打了。
She definitely hit it very hard.
她确实打得很重。
How was that for you?
那对你来说感觉怎么样？
Um, I'm used to having a lot of siblings, and I get beat up by them all the time. So it didn't really hurt me.
嗯，我习惯了有很多兄弟姐妹，我总是被他们揍。所以这对我来说其实不疼。
Why did that work?
为什么这样会有用？
I don't know. [CHUCKLES]
我不知道。[轻笑]
It's funny. I wonder if it worked because she was sort of nice about it. Like, you came to her all mad, and then she didn't get mad back. Instead, she greeted your anger with niceness.
这很有趣。我在想，是不是因为她态度比较好才起作用的？比如，你带着满腔怒火去找她，而她没有以牙还牙地发火。相反，她用友善回应了你的怒气。
I don't really know why she acted nice to me when I was frustrated.
我真的不知道为什么我在沮丧时她对我那么好。
Have you ever heard of this phrase, "turn the other cheek"?
你听说过“回敬另一边脸”这个短语吗？
No.
没有。
It's something that I think Jesus said. He said that if somebody slaps you on your right cheek-- like, you know, slaps you on the cheek of your face-- he says, turn the other cheek, and offer the other cheek as well. Even if somebody's mad at you and does something unreasonable, you shouldn't get unreasonable yourself.
我想这是耶稣说过的话。他说，如果有人打你的右脸——你知道的，就是打你的脸颊——他建议，要把另一边脸也转过去让他打。即使有人对你发火，做了不合理的事，你也不应该表现得不合理。
Probably.
也许吧。
And in this case, your sister turned the other cheek, but it was her butt cheek that she turned.
在这种情况下，你姐姐转过了另一边脸，但她转过来的是她的屁股。
[CHUCKLES] That's funny.
[轻笑] 那真好笑。
But it wasn't just Johanna who led them to a quick, peaceful resolution. Both girls agree that if Mae hadn't asked for what she wanted at the door, if she just punched Johanna, Johanna would have punched back. It would have escalated. Johanna admits she's not always so calm and reasonable with Mae. But this time, it was clear how to handle her, and Johanna knew exactly what to do.
但这不仅仅是Johanna引导她们快速和平解决问题。两个女孩都同意，如果Mae在门口没有说出她的想法，如果她只是打了Johanna，Johanna肯定会打回去。事情就会升级。Johanna承认她对Mae并不总是那么冷静和讲理。但这一次，处理她的方法很明确，Johanna完全知道该怎么做。
And she got what she wanted, so I think that made her happy.
而且她得到了她想要的，所以我认为这让她很开心。
I think that's true. Yeah. Like, you didn't say no to her.
我觉得是真的。是啊。你没有拒绝她。
Yeah. I've been here for six-- I've been with her for six years of my life. I know her pretty well. I've known her for her whole life, so I get to watch a whole entire movie about her in my mind.
是的。我在这里待了六——我和她在一起生活了六年。我很了解她。我从她出生起就认识她，所以我脑海里就像一直在看一部关于她的电影。
And so you know what to do.
所以你知道该怎么做。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, today on our show, in these noisy, aggressive times where the people rising to power in this world seem to come in hot, lots of fiery tempers and scrunched-up fists and twitchering legs, we pause for a moment to remember there is another path. We have stories of people turning the other cheek, pausing, and trying against all odds to see the good in each other, giving themselves over to the feeling in that old Otis Redding song--
好了，今天在我们的节目中，在这个嘈杂、充满侵略性的时代，那些在这个世界上崛起的人似乎总是气势汹汹，带着火爆的脾气、紧握的拳头和抽动的双腿，我们暂停片刻，记住还有另一条道路。我们有一些故事，讲述人们如何回敬另一边脸，暂停一下，并在极尽所能的情况下看到彼此的优点，让自己沉浸在Otis Redding那首老歌的情感中——
["TRY A
LITTLE TENDERNESS" BY OTIS REDDING]
Stay tuned for a hardboiled detective, for crows with a vendetta, for righteous spankings and non-spankings, for John Mulaney, and for a bus driver who thought he was God. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
敬请期待一位硬汉侦探，关于怀恨在心的乌鸦，关于正义的责打与非责打，关于John Mulaney，以及一位自以为是上帝的公交车司机。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One. So there's an entire genre of movies and other stories, where tough guys who have been through it all and seen the worst in people decide they're going to soften, try a little tenderness, help somebody out who needs the help. This happens in old westerns, sci-fi films, spy stories.
这是《美国生活》，第一幕。有一个完整的电影和故事流派，讲述那些经历过一切、看透了人性中最糟糕一面的硬汉们，决定要变得温柔一点，尝试一点点体贴，去帮助那些需要帮助的人。这种情况发生在老西部片、科幻电影、间谍故事中。
And there's a story like that on stage right now, on Broadway in New York. And I saw this a couple of weeks ago and thought, this story would be perfect for the radio. And the director and producers and writers said, yes. The show is called All In. And it stars John Mulaney, Richard Kind, Fred Armisen, and Chloe Fineman.
现在纽约百老汇的舞台上也有这样一个故事。我几周前看了这部剧，觉得这个故事非常适合在广播里播出。导演、制片人和编剧都同意了。这部剧叫《All In》。由John Mulaney、Richard Kind、Fred Armisen和Chloe Fineman主演。
And what they're doing is they're performing a set of short stories on stage by the writer Simon Rich, who's been on our show a few times with his stories. And let's get right to it. This story is one of the stories in their show. It's called "The Big Nap."
他们正在舞台上表演作家Simon Rich的一系列短篇小说，他之前在我们的节目中讲过几次故事。我们直接进入主题吧。这个故事是他们剧中的一个短篇。它叫《大睡一觉》。
[TYPEWRITER KEYS CLACKING, CARRIAGE RETURN]
[打字机键声，换行声]
Chapter one. I woke up just after dawn. It was a typical morning. My knees were scraped and bruised. My clothes were damp and soiled. And my teeth felt like someone had socked me in the jaw. I reached for the bottle I kept under my pillow and took a sloppy swig. The taste was foul, but it did the trick. Now, I could sit up and think. Now, I could start to figure out how to somehow face another goddamn day. I stared at my reflection in the mirror. I wasn't getting any younger. I was two years old.
第一章。我在黎明后醒来。这是一个典型的早晨。我的膝盖被擦伤和淤青了。我的衣服又湿又脏。我的牙齿感觉就像有人狠狠地揍了我的下巴。我伸手去拿放在枕头底下的瓶子，大口灌了一口。味道很难闻，但确实管用。现在，我可以坐起来思考了。现在，我可以开始琢磨如何去面对该死的又一天了。我盯着镜子里的倒影。我不再年轻了。我才两岁。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Soon, I would be three, unless I stayed two. I wasn't sure if you stayed the age you were or if that changed. I wasn't sure about a lot of things. All I knew was I was tired. Tired of this down and dirty life. Tired of trying to make some sense out of a world gone mad.
很快，我就要三岁了，除非我一直保持两岁。我不确定你是会保持现在的年龄，还是会有所改变。我不确定很多事情。我只知道我很累。厌倦了这个肮脏的生活。厌倦了试图从一个疯狂的世界里理出头绪。
The client was waiting for me in my nursery. I'd seen her around before. She'd come on the scene about a year ago, moving into the white bassinet down the hall. Some people called her "sweetheart." Others called her "pumpkin." But most people knew her by her full name, Baby Zoe.
客户正在我的托儿所里等我。我以前见过她。她大约一年前出现在现场，搬进了走廊尽头的白色摇篮里。有些人叫她“甜心”。其他人叫她“南瓜”。但大多数人叫她的全名，Zoe宝贝。
[DRAMATIC PIANO CHORD]
[戏剧性的钢琴和弦]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Sure, she looked innocent enough with her big, wide eyes and her Princess Elsa onesie. But her past was murky. Some said she came from the hospital, but there was also a rumor she'd once lived inside Mommy's tummy. It didn't add up. Still, a job's a job. So what brings you here to see me?
当然，她看起来很天真，有着一双圆圆的大眼睛和她的Elsa公主连体衣。但她的过去很模糊。有人说她来自医院，但也有传言说她曾经住在妈咪的肚子里。这说不通。不过，工作就是工作。是什么风把你吹来找我了？
It's Moomoo. She's missing.
是Moomoo。她不见了。
[DRAMATIC PIANO CHORD]
[戏剧性的钢琴和弦]
I rolled my eyes. Moomoo went missing all the time. It was just the kind of unicorn she was. Maybe she's under your bassinet.
我翻了个白眼。Moomoo总是失踪。这就是那只独角兽的德行。也许她在你的摇篮下面。
I checked. She's not.
我找过了。不在那。
Her eyes filled with tears. I handed her a tissue, but she didn't know what a tissue was, so she put it in her mouth and tried to eat it.
她的眼睛里充满了泪水。我递给她一张纸巾，但她不知道纸巾是什么，所以她把它放进嘴里试图吃掉。
(MUFFLED) Please, Moomoo's all I have in this whole wide world!
（声音模糊）求你了，Moomoo是我这辈子拥有的全部！
Lost toys are small time. Why should I bust my ass trying to find some unicorn? Probably just turn up under the radiator.
丢失的玩具是小事。我为什么要拼了命去找什么独角兽？可能只是在暖气片底下。
Because I can pay you upfront.
因为我可以提前支付报酬。
I cocked my head doubtfully. What kind of scratch could a baby like Zoe come up with? She didn't have a piggy bank. She wasn't old enough to have pockets.
我怀疑地歪着头。像Zoe这样的婴儿能拿出什么钱来？她没有存钱罐。她还没有大到有口袋。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What have you got that's worth me getting up for?
你有什么值得我起身的东西吗？
Stickers.
贴纸。
I swallowed. Are they the, uh-- the fun kind?
我吞了口唾沫。是那种，呃——有趣的吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
See for yourself.
你自己看看。
They were fun, all right. I'd never seen so many Batmans in all my life. How do I know these aren't hot? Where'd you even get them?
确实很有趣。我这辈子从来没见过这么多蝙蝠侠贴纸。我怎么知道这些不是赃物？你从哪搞来的？
I don't remember. Sometimes things are just in my hand. I also don't remember how I got into this room or what we're talking about.
我不记得了。有时候东西就在我手里。我也不记得我是怎么进这个房间的，或者我们在说什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We're talking about how I'm gonna find your Moomoo.
我们在说我该怎么找到你的Moomoo。
You mean it?
你说真的？
That's right, doll. I'm on the case. Chapter two. So this is the rug where you last saw your Moomoo?
没错，小宝贝。我正在调查。第二章。这就是你最后一次见到Moomoo的地毯吗？
Yes, someone must have taken her.
是的，肯定是有人拿走了她。
Have you seen any suspicious characters around lately?
你最近有没有看到什么可疑的人？
Not that I can remember.
我记得没有。
Think hard.
好好想想。
Well, now that you mention it, an old lady appeared out of nowhere yesterday and replaced my parents.
嗯，既然你提到了，昨天有个老太太突然出现，取代了我的父母。
Interesting. Describe her.
有意思。描述一下她。
Gray hair, glasses, smells like yogurt.
灰头发，眼镜，闻起来像酸奶。
Large, wooden jewelry?
很大的木制首饰？
Yeah.
是的。
Sounds like Nana.
听起来像是Nana。
[DRAMATIC PIANO CHORD]
[戏剧性的钢琴和弦]
You know her?
你认识她？
I've had run-ins with her before.
我以前和她有过冲突。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She's from Florida.
她是来自佛罗里达的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Where's Florida?
佛罗里达在哪里？
It's in the sky.
在天上。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
How do you get there?
怎么去那里？
You get in an airplane, and you watch cartoons. And when you wake up, you're in her house, and there's a turkey.
你坐上一架飞机，看动画片。当你醒来时，你就已经在她家了，还有火鸡。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
If Nana's from Florida, what's she doing here?
如果Nana来自佛罗里达，她在这里干什么？
That's what I'm gonna find out. Chapter three. Nana was elusive. Sometimes she was lying in a recliner. Sometimes she was small inside a phone.
这就是我要查出来的。第三章。Nana神出鬼没。有时她躺在躺椅上。有时她变小钻进手机里。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
If I was going to track her down, I needed good old-fashioned shoe leather. First, I tried the playroom. Then, I tried the room that has the chairs. I'd been at it for over 10 seconds when I finally caught a break in the case. Nana picked me up and started carrying me. Before long, she was making a phone call.
如果我要追踪她，我得靠老派的方式。首先，我试了游戏室。然后，我试了那个有椅子的房间。我才查了不到10秒钟，案情就有了突破。Nana抱起了我，开始带着我走。没过多久，她就在打电话。
How's the Airbnb? Are you both wearing sunscreen? Listen, I can't figure out the Bosch.
Airbnb怎么样？你们两个都涂防晒霜了吗？听着，我搞不定那个博世洗衣机。
It was impossible to follow. Like all grownups, Nana spoke in a secret code designed to keep her operations hidden.
这根本没法追踪。像所有成年人一样，Nana用的是一种秘密代码，专门用来隐藏她的行踪。
What does Smart Cycle mean? Warm or cold? Hold on. I'm putting you on speaker.
“智能循环”是什么意思？温水还是冷水？等等。我开免提。
And that's when a familiar voice rumbled out of Nana's phone.
就在这时，一个熟悉的声音从Nana的手机里传了出来。
We're driving to the beach. Just google it, OK?
我们正在开车去海滩。你自己去谷歌一下，好吗？
There was no mistaking it. The voice belonged to Mama. And that could only mean one thing. This one went all the way to the top.
绝对没错。这个声音属于妈咪。那只能意味着一件事。这件事牵扯到了幕后大老板。
[DRAMATIC PIANO CHORD]
[戏剧性的钢琴和弦]
Chapter four. I'm off the case.
第四章。我不干了。
What? But you said you'd help me.
什么？但你说你会帮我的。
That was before I knew the score. If Mama's mixed up in this, I don't want anything to do with it.
那是没了解情况之前。如果妈咪也卷进来了，我可不想沾边。
Ugh. What's wrong with Mama? I like Mama.
啊。妈咪怎么了？我喜欢妈咪。
We all like Mama. She smells nice and is warm. But that doesn't change the fact that she runs this whole goddamn town.
我们都喜欢妈咪。她闻起来很香，而且很温暖。但这并不能改变她统治整个该死小镇的事实。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
Look, you're just a kid, so I'll spell it out for you. Mama's the big boss around here. The doctor, the dentist, the Gymboree instructor. They're all on the take.
听着，你只是个孩子，那我给你解释清楚。妈咪是这里的大老板。医生、牙医、金宝贝早教老师。他们都被收买了。
But I thought Dadda was in charge.
但我以为爸爸是负责的。
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
哈，哈，哈，哈！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Dadda. Dadda's just a bagman! He wears a shiny watch. It's Mama's the one that's calling all the shots.
爸爸。爸爸只是个传声筒！他戴着一块闪亮的手表。妈咪才是说了算的人。
Well-- well, what does this have to do with Moomoo?
那——那这和Moomoo有什么关系？
Oh, don't you get it? This is bigger than Moomoo. Something's going down here, and I'm not hanging around long enough to find out what it is.
噢，你还不明白吗？这比Moomoo严重多了。有什么事情要发生了，我可不会留在这里等死。
I was halfway to my crib when the girl began to sob. It didn't take a detective to see she was frightened. Her eyes were bleary, her face pale and drawn, and at some point, she had pooped big in her pants.
我走到一半回婴儿床时，那个女孩开始抽泣。不需要什么侦探就能看出她被吓坏了。她眼神呆滞，脸色苍白憔悴，而且不知道什么时候她在裤子里拉了一大坨。
Please! You've got to help me!
求你了！你一定要帮帮我！
I got enough problems of my own. Why should I risk my hide to help some dame I barely even know?
我自己已经够多麻烦了。我为什么要冒着生命危险去帮一个我几乎不认识的女人？
Because you're the only one who can!
因为只有你能做到！
Chapter five. I shuffled down the hall, trying to figure out why I'd gotten mixed up in this crazy case. Was it just for the Batmans? Or was it something else? There was something about that screwy kid. The world had done her dirty, but somehow it hadn't made us cynical. She still believed in justice. She still believed in hope. She still believed that objects disappeared when you put a surface in front of her, and then reappeared by magic when you took away that surface.
第五章。我拖着脚步走在走廊里，试图弄清楚为什么我会卷进这个疯狂的案子。难道只是为了蝙蝠贴纸吗？还是别的原因？那个古怪的孩子身上有些特别的地方。世界对她很不公平，但不知为何她并没有变得愤世嫉俗。她依然相信正义。她依然相信希望。她依然相信当你把一个平面放在她面前时物体就会消失，而当你移开平面时它们又会神奇地重新出现。
She even believed in me. No one ever had before. I decided to swing by the TV room. Classic grownup hangout. The kind of after-hours joint that doesn't get hoppin' till after bedtime. I slipped inside and got to work, opening drawers, taking things out, and then dropping them hard on the ground. It's an old detective tactic, a way to make sure that you touched everything and that everything got everywhere. I'd gone through most of the cabinets when the door burst open. It was Nana. I spotted a closet and sprinted inside, but it turned out to be a dead end.
她甚至相信我。从来没有人相信过我。我决定去电视室转转。那是典型的成年人聚集地。那种直到睡前才开始热闹的地方。我溜进去开始干活，打开抽屉，把东西拿出来，然后用力扔在地上。这是一种老派侦探战术，为了确保你碰过每一件东西，而且让所有东西到处都是。我刚检查完大部分橱柜，门就砰地打开了。是Nana。我发现了一个壁橱，冲了进去，但结果是个死胡同。
How about a nap?
睡个午觉怎么样？
I shook my head defiantly. If she thought I was going down that easy, she had another thing coming.
我叛逆地摇了摇头。如果她以为我这么容易就范，那她就错了。
How about some yummy medicine?
来点美味的药药怎么样？
I ate the medicine. I like to eat things that were yummy, and Nana had used that word when describing the medicine. I smiled as the sweet cherry capsule hit my tongue, but it was quickly followed by a different flavor. The bitter taste of betrayal.
我吃了药。我喜欢吃美味的东西，Nana在描述药物时用过那个词。当甜甜的樱桃药囊触碰到舌尖时，我微笑了，但很快换成了另一种味道。背叛的苦味。
Chapter six. It wasn't the first time I'd been drugged.
第六章。这不是我第一次被下药了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Still, you couldn't help but marvel at the grownups' depravity. They never did you dirty to your face. Haha, no. They preferred to stab you in the back. They said you could skip your vegetables and snuck them in your mashed potatoes. They said you could sleep in their bed, then they put you in your crib the second you fall asleep. They said you could have a present, and then brought you a potty with a bow on it and told you to poop in it in front of them. Like that's some kind of a gift!
尽管如此，你还是不得不惊叹成年人的卑劣。他们从不当面整你。哈哈，不。他们喜欢背后捅刀子。他们说你可以不吃蔬菜，然后偷偷把它们藏在土豆泥里。他们说你可以睡在他们的床上，然后等你一睡着就把你放进摇篮。他们说你可以收到一份礼物，然后带给你一个带蝴蝶结的马桶，让你当着他们的面拉屎。就像那是什么礼物一样！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I stared out the bars of my crib. The grownups had taken my power and my freedom. But that just meant I had nothing left to lose.
我盯着婴儿床的栏杆。大人们夺走了我的权力和自由。但这反倒意味着我没什么可失去的了。
Chapter seven!
第七章！
Where have you been? I looked everywhere. Inside a cup, inside a shoe--
你去哪了？我到处都找了。杯子里，鞋子里——
I can't fit in any of those places.
我装不进那些地方。
Why not?
为什么？
'Cause I'm too big!
因为我太大了！
But when you're far away, you look small.
但当你离得很远时，你看上去很小。
Objects look big when they're close to you and small when they're far from you.
物体离你近的时候看起来很大，远的时候看起来很小。
Oh, god! What's happening?
噢，天呐！发生什么事了？
Nana tried to kill me! She drugged me and left me to die inside my crib.
Nana想杀了我！她给我下了药，让我死在婴儿床里。
How did you escape?
你是怎么逃出来的？
I said Nana, up, and then Nana came and picked me up.
我说Nana，起来，然后Nana就过来把我抱起来了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Why did she try to help you after trying to kill you?
为什么她试图杀你之后又来帮你？
Why do you think? She's insane.
你觉得呢？她疯了。
So what do we do?
那我们该怎么办？
We run. Let's run away together. Somewhere far, far away where we can make a brand new start. Maybe the den!
我们跑。我们一起逃跑吧。去一个很远很远的地方，在那里我们可以重新开始。也许是书房！
We'll never make it!
我们跑不掉的！
Anything's better than hanging around here like a couple of sitting ducks.
什么都比像待宰羔羊一样呆在这里强。
Look!
看！
She pointed across the room. Nana was headed for the stairs, carrying a clear plastic bag.
她指着房间对面。Nana正朝楼梯走去，手里提着一个透明塑料袋。
It's Moomoo! She's in there. Oh, god! Where's Nana taking her?!
是Moomoo！她在里面。噢，天呐！Nana要带她去哪？！
The garage.
车库。
What's that?
那是什么？
It's the car's bedroom, where it sleeps. Also, there's a big door that goes up and down and is a monster.
那是车的卧室，它睡觉的地方。而且，那里有个大门会上下移动，是个怪物。
Well, you can't go down there. You'll disappear.
嗯，你不能去那里。你会消失的。
I won't disappear. Objects are permanent. Even when you can't see them, they are still there.
我不会消失的。物体是永恒的。即使你看不到它们，它们依然在那里。
Oh, god! I can't lose you, too!
噢，天呐！我也不能失去你！
You won't. I promise.
你不会的。我保证。
Chapter eight. I climbed down the stairs as silently as possible while also still counting out loud to myself, because that's the game I do when I climb stairs.
第八章。我悄无声息地爬下楼梯，同时还在大声数数，因为那是爬楼梯时我玩的游戏。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
As my eyes adjusted to the darkness, I realized Nana was not alone. Mama and Dadda had returned.
当我的眼睛适应了黑暗，我意识到Nana并不孤单。妈咪和爸爸回来了。
What happened?
发生什么事了？
It's not my fault. It's the damn Bosch. Why does it have to have so many settings?
不怪我。是该死的博世洗衣机。为什么它有那么多设置？
I was starting to lose the thread, but then I saw something that made my blood run cold. It was Moomoo, just where Zoe had said she'd be in the plastic bag. There was only one problem. She'd been murdered. Her horn had been severed, and her hooves ripped clean off her body. Nana had taken her life, and now, Mama was back to run the coverup. I watched with disgust as Dadda obediently tossed Moomoo's corpse into the trash.
我开始理不清头绪，但随后我看到了让我血液凝固的一幕。那是Moomoo，正像Zoe说的那样在塑料袋里。只有一个问题。她被谋杀了。她的角被割掉了，蹄子从身体上被硬生生扯了下来。Nana夺走了她的生命，现在，妈咪回来了掩盖真相。我厌恶地看着爸爸顺从地把Moomoo的尸体扔进了垃圾桶。
Don't worry. She'll never know. [CYNICAL CHUCKLE]
别担心。她永远不会知道的。[愤世嫉俗的笑]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I followed the grownups up the stairs. I was almost at the top when I heard a disconcerting sound. Laughter!
我跟着大人们上楼。我快走到顶端时，听到了一声令人不安的声音。笑声！
(LAUGHING) Look! Mama found Moomoo!
（笑着）看！妈咪找到Moomoo了！
I broke out in a cold sweat as I watched Mama take a new unicorn out of a plastic case. Zoe. Zoe, listen to me. That's not the real Moomoo. The real Moomoo is dead.
当我看着妈咪从塑料盒子里拿出一个新的独角兽时，我惊出了一身冷汗。Zoe。Zoe，听着。那不是真正的Moomoo。真正的Moomoo已经死了。
But this looks like Moomoo.
但这个看起来像Moomoo啊。
No, I know. I can't explain it, but you gotta believe me. I saw them bury her body. I saw it with my own damn eyes.
不，我知道。我解释不清楚，但你必须相信我。我亲眼看着他们埋葬了她的尸体。我亲眼看到的。
But Mama said this was Moomoo. She used the word, "Moomoo," and pointed at it.
但妈咪说这就是Moomoo。她用了“Moomoo”这个词，还指着它。
I grabbed her by the shoulders. You can't trust Mama. You can't trust any of them. They're all in on this together! Don't buy into their lies!
我抓住她的肩膀。你不能相信妈咪。你不能相信他们中的任何一个。他们是一伙的！不要相信他们的谎言！
[ZOE YELLING]
[ZOE尖叫]
Easy, sweetie. Remember, we play gentle.
轻松点，亲爱的。记住，我们玩的时候要温柔。
The grownups were closing in on me. I didn't have much time. Zoe, baby, they're going to nab me any second. But before they do, please, I need to hear you say something. I need to hear you say that you believe me. I need to hear you say that this isn't Moomoo.
大人们正在逼近我。我没多少时间了。Zoe，宝贝，他们随时会抓住我。但在那之前，求你了，我需要听你说句话。我需要听你说你相信我。我需要听你说这不是Moomoo。
But Mama said it was.
但妈咪说是。
Whew. I thought we had something. Something real. I suppose I've been a fool. I'll just take my Batmans and go.
呼。我原以为我们有什么共识。真实的东西。我想我真是个傻瓜。我还是带着我的蝙蝠侠贴纸走吧。
Uh-oh, looks like someone got into the Hanukkah drawer.
呃哦，看起来有人溜进了光明节抽屉。
I watched with silent rage as Mama snatched the stickers from my hand.
我愤怒地看着妈咪从我手里抢走了贴纸。
He's going through a phase, sneaking around, getting into everything. He thinks he's a little detective.
他正在经历一个阶段，到处溜达，什么都碰。他以为自己是个小侦探。
[GROWNUPS LAUGHING]
[大人们笑]
The grownups laughed in my face. And as the sick coffee breath hit my nose, something snapped inside my brain. Before I could stop myself, I was lunging at them, arms flailing and legs kicking.
大人们嘲笑我的脸。当恶心的咖啡味扑鼻而来时，我脑子里有什么东西崩断了。没等我停下来，我就冲向他们，挥舞着手臂，又踢又闹。
Terrible twos! Ha, ha, ha!
可怕的两岁！哈，哈，哈！
I punched and spat as the grownups tried to restrain me. But I was determined not to break this time, no. This time, I wasn't going down without a fight!
大人们试图制服我时，我挥拳又吐。但我这次决心不屈服，不。这一次，我绝不会不战而败！
How about some yummy medicine?
来点美味的药药怎么样？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I woke hours later. My mind was so foggy, it took me a second to realize I wasn't there alone. Staring up at me from the rug was Baby Zoe. What the hell are you doing here?
几小时后我醒了。我的大脑一片混沌，花了一秒钟才意识到我不是独自一人。地毯上盯着我看的是Zoe宝贝。你在这干什么？
I brought this for you.
我给你带了这个。
She slid something to me through the bars of my crib. I-- I couldn't make it out in the darkness, but I could feel. Soft cape, groovy hooves, fun horn. Oh, don't be crazy, kid. This Moomoo is all you have.
她穿过婴儿床的栏杆把东西递给我。我——我在黑暗中认不出它，但我能摸出来。柔软的斗篷，帅气的蹄子，有趣的角。噢，别傻了，孩子。这个Moomoo是你拥有的全部。
I want us to be square. Besides, it's not like it's the real Moomoo.
我想让我们扯平。再说，这又不是真正的Moomoo。
What are you saying?
你在说什么？
I'm saying I believe you. Anyways, see you around.
我是说我相信你。总之，后会有期。
She started to crawl away. She was halfway across the very small rug she was on when I said, wait, hey! Hold on now. This case isn't closed. A lot remains unsolved.
她开始爬开。当她爬到那块很小的地毯中间时，我说，等等，嘿！先别走。这个案子还没结。还有很多未解之谜。
Like what?
比如什么？
We still don't know why Mama and Dadda went away this weekend. Or where they went or what they did there. We don't know why they go to work or what work is, or why they both have glasses.
我们仍然不知道为什么妈咪和爸爸这个周末要离开。或者他们去了哪里，在那里做了什么。我们不知道他们为什么要上班，工作是什么，或者为什么他们都戴眼镜。
We don't know their penis and vagina situation. Or why they take showers and not baths. We don't even know if Mama and Dadda are their real names.
我们不知道他们的阴茎和阴道情况。或者为什么他们洗澡而不是洗盆浴。我们甚至不知道妈咪和爸爸是不是他们的真名。
That's a lot to crack.
那可够难查的。
Sure, but I was thinking maybe it'd be easier if we cut a deal.
当然，但我在想如果我们达成协议会不会容易些。
What are you saying?
你在说什么？
I'm saying partners. You and me.
我是说合作。你和我。
Well, I don't have any experience. You'd have to train me.
嗯，我没有任何经验。你得训练我。
It won't take long. We can start right now. I handed her a crayon to take notes.
用不了多久。我们现在就可以开始。我递给她一支蜡笔来做记录。
Is this food?
这是吃的吗？
Sort of.
算是吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, I'm completely lost. I don't know where I am, and I forgot what time it is! I-- I don't know if I'm awake or if this is a dream! And also, I do not understand mirrors.
好的，我完全迷糊了。我不知道我在哪，我忘了现在是几点！我——我不知道我是醒着还是在做梦！而且，我完全不理解镜子。
Don't worry, kiddo. We'll figure it all out. Together.
别担心，小家伙。我们会搞清楚一切的。一起。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
John Mulaney, Chloe Fineman, Richard Kind, and Fred Armisen. They're the stars of All In: Comedy About Love. But the cast is going to change soon and star other great people. The show was written by Simon Rich. It runs through February 16 on Broadway, New York City, at the Hudson Theater. Coming up-- how do you get a wild animal that hates your guts to turn the other cheek, especially if it doesn't have cheeks? That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio-- when our program continues.
John Mulaney、Chloe Fineman、Richard Kind和Fred Armisen。他们是《All In: Comedy About Love》的主演。但演员阵容很快就会改变，会有其他伟大的演员加入。该剧由Simon Rich编剧。它将于2月16日在纽约百老汇的哈德森剧院上演。接下来——你如何让一只厌恶你的野生动物转过另一边脸，尤其是如果它根本没有脸颊？一分钟后在芝加哥公共广播电台——节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Try a Little Tenderness," we have stories of people putting aside aggressiveness and anger and disappointment in other human beings, and reaching out in kindness instead. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Gladiator, starring Ruffled Crow. Aviva DeKornfeld brings us this story about a person who tried to be considerate and where it got him.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目主题是“尝试一点点温柔”，我们讲述了人们抛开侵略性、愤怒和对他人的失望，转而伸出友善之手的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《角斗士》，由愤怒的乌鸦主演。Aviva DeKornfeld给我们带来了这个故事，关于一个试图体贴他人却得到这种下场的人。
This story starts with a little tenderness. Alan Martin's a real nature lover, spends as much time as possible hiking around the mountains and bird-watching near his home in Vancouver. So it pained him when he had to cut a big tree down in his front yard. Because he didn't want to disturb any of the animals living in it. But the tree was starting to rot, and he was afraid it would fall onto his house.
这个故事始于一点点温柔。Alan Martin是个真正的自然爱好者，花尽可能多的时间在温哥华附近的群山中徒步和观鸟。所以当他不得不砍掉前院的一棵大树时，他非常痛苦。因为他不想打扰住在树上的任何动物。但那棵树开始腐烂，他担心它会倒在他的房子上。
And so like the sensitive environmental scientist that he is, Alan waited until autumn, when he knew that nesting season was over. And then, just to be extra careful, he brought in an arborist to assess the tree to make sure he wouldn't be messing with any little critters' homes. He got the OK and hired a couple guys to cut the tree down while he stood by, directing them this way and that. And then, the next morning, Alan stepped out of his house, and--
作为一个敏感的环境科学家，Alan等到秋天，他知道筑巢季节已经结束时。然后，为了格外小心，他请了一位树艺师来评估这棵树，确保不会破坏任何小生物的家园。他得到了许可，雇了几个伙计砍树，他站在旁边指挥着他们。第二天早上，Alan走出屋子——
There was this crow sitting in the front lawn, and at a close distance to the steps. And it's just staring right at me. [CHUCKLES]
那有一只乌鸦坐在前草坪上，距离台阶很近。它正盯着我看。[轻笑]
That's very weird.
那很奇怪。
It was a bit off-putting. I couldn't quite figure it out, but I walked down my path. And as soon as the crow was out of my sight, that's when I got this thump on the back of my head.
让人有点不安。我不太明白，但我走下小路。就在乌鸦消失在视线之外时，我的后脑勺挨了一下。
Out of the corner of his eye, Alan saw the crow fly past him. And he thought, did that crow just hit me? It hurt.
Alan用眼角余光看到乌鸦从他身边飞过。他想，那只乌鸦刚刚撞了我吗？很疼。
And then I did a few little experiments. I would turn away purposely and walk away, and it would leave the power line, attending another hit. And I would turn around just in time, and it would swoop away. And I did this a couple of times. It was just clearly waiting for me to turn away, so that it could hit me in the back of the head.
然后我做了一些小实验。我故意转身走开，它就离开了电线，发动另一次攻击。我及时转过身，它就俯冲走开了。我这样做了几次。它显然在等我转身，好撞击我的后脑勺。
Alan thought, OK, maybe this crow didn't live in this tree, but it must have meant something to it. He knew that crows are really smart, but they're also very vengeful birds and territorial. And so a short while later, when he walked out of his house--
Alan想，好吧，也许这只乌鸦不住在树里，但它对这棵树一定有什么感情。他知道乌鸦很聪明，但也非常记仇且具有领地意识。所以不久之后，当他走出家门——
I came out, and there was a crow sitting on the line. But it was a different crow.
我出来时，有一只乌鸦坐在电线上。但那是一只不同的乌鸦。
How could you tell?
你怎么看出来的？
It-- it was smaller. It was a bit smaller, and it wasn't as bulky.
它——它比较小。体型小一点，没那么臃肿。
OK.
好的。
This crow, when I came outside, it caught at me, as if it almost recognized me, as if, oh, that's the guy. It cawed, and then it left. It flew down the block. And there's a green space at the end of the street. And about a minute later, it came back with the enforcer crow.
我出来时，这只乌鸦对着我叫，仿佛它几乎认出我了，仿佛，“噢，就是那个人”。它叫了一声，然后离开了。它飞向街区另一头。街尽头有一块绿地。大约一分钟后，它带着那只执法者乌鸦回来了。
This smaller crow, snitching on Alan to the bigger crow-- this is a real thing. I ran Alan's story by a crow researcher named Loma Pendergraft. Loma said that if a crow sees something it deems dangerous, it will sound an alarm to summon other crows. And if they agree there's a threat, they'll dive-bomb. This whole routine is called "mobbing."
这只小乌鸦，向大乌鸦告发Alan——这可是真事。我把Alan的故事告诉了一位叫Loma Pendergraft的乌鸦研究员。Loma说，如果乌鸦看到它认为危险的东西，它会发出警报召集其他乌鸦。如果它们一致认为存在威胁，它们就会俯冲攻击。这一整套例程被称为“聚众攻击”。
Some people, attacked by a murder of crows-- they'd be angry. Not Alan or his family.
有些人，如果被一群乌鸦攻击——肯定会很生气。但Alan和他的家人没有。
We felt bad. Because we realized we'd hurt these crows.
我们感觉很糟糕。因为我们意识到我们伤害了这些乌鸦。
Hmm. Well, that's a very nice reaction.
嗯。那真是非常好的反应。
[CHUCKLES] Yeah, that was initially. But as the harassment persisted over the coming days, it became a source of anxiety, just going outside. So the compassion for the crow, I would say, waned over time a little bit because of that. And my next questions were, how long is this going to go on for?
[轻笑] 是的，最初是那样。但随着接下来几天骚扰的持续，这变成了一种焦虑的来源，仅仅是走出门就觉得焦虑。所以对乌鸦的同情心，我想随着时间的推移减弱了一些。我的下一个问题是，这种情况还要持续多久？
Science actually has an answer to this question. It turns out crows can hold grudges for a very long time. Back in 2006, John Marzluff, who is a professor in wildlife science at the University of Washington-- he set up an experiment to test this. He put on this ugly, orange, ogre mask and walked around an area where he knew crows lived. And then, he captured a bunch of the crows while the rest of the flock looked on. Then he released them. The point was to distress the crows, but not hurt them.
科学实际上对这个问题有答案。事实证明，乌鸦可以长时间记仇。早在2006年，华盛顿大学野生动物科学教授John Marzluff做了一个实验来测试这一点。他戴上一个丑陋的、橙色的食人魔面具，走在他知道乌鸦居住的区域。然后，他在其他同类观察的情况下抓了一堆乌鸦。然后释放了它们。目的是让乌鸦感到痛苦，而不是伤害它们。
And then, for the next 17 years, every time he put on his ogre mask and walked around the place where he first captured the birds, the crows would swarm him. For years, each time he returned, more and more crows would join in. Because crows not only remember their enemies, but pass their grievances onto their crow children and grandchildren. Alan was not aware of all of that. So for weeks, he'd leave his house every day, hoping the birds had finally forgotten about him. No such luck. So he tried a new tactic.
然后在接下来的17年里，每次他戴上食人魔面具出现在首次捕获鸟类的地方，乌鸦就会蜂拥而上围攻他。多年来，每当他回来时，就会有更多的乌鸦加入。因为乌鸦不仅记得它们的敌人，还会把怨恨传给它们的乌鸦子女和孙子辈。Alan并不了解这一切。所以几个星期以来，他每天出门都希望鸟儿们终于忘记他了。很遗憾并没有。于是他尝试了一种新战术。
I put on a wig and a beard, and the crow was looking hard. It was kind of turning its head a bit, side to side. You can tell it was trying to figure out who this was. But it didn't recognize me.
我戴上了假发和胡子，乌鸦死死地盯着看。它歪着脑袋，左右看了看。你可以看出它在试图弄清楚这是谁。但它没认出我。
Just a PSA. There are other ways to ward off an angry crow, should you not have a wig on hand. You can hide yourself under an umbrella so the crows can't see you. Or you can wear sunglasses backwards.
顺便提个建议。如果你手头没有假发，还有其他方法可以抵御愤怒的乌鸦。你可以藏在伞下，这样乌鸦就看不见你了。或者你可以把墨镜反戴。
Apparently, crows understand that sunglasses go on your eyes. And they know that if you can see them, you can potentially hurt them. So they won't attack the back of your sunglassed head, because they think you have an extra set of eyes back there. Anyway, Alan's disguise-- it was working perfectly for him.
显然，乌鸦明白墨镜是戴在眼睛上的。它们知道如果你能看到它们，你可能会伤害它们。所以它们不会攻击你反戴墨镜的后脑勺，因为它们认为你后面也长了眼睛。总之，Alan的伪装——对他来说非常有效。
And then, I ripped off the beard and the wig, and the crow flipped. It flipped out.
然后，我扯掉了胡子和假发，乌鸦崩溃了。它彻底崩溃了。
Really?
真的吗？
It did a backflip.
它做了一个后空翻。
What? Oh, it literally flipped out?
什么？噢，它字面上崩溃了？
It just literally-- it kind of flipped back, up into the air a little bit. But it was completely in shock and extremely pissed off. Like, how dare you?
它只是字面上——它向后翻了一下，飞到空中一点点。但它完全震惊了，而且非常愤怒。仿佛，你竟敢这样？
It sounds like you're developing a whole kind of relationship with these birds, almost.
听起来你几乎和这些鸟建立了一种完整的关系。
Yeah. It's a relationship of antagonism, and it's not a rewarding one.
是的。这是一种敌对的关系，而且不是一种有益的关系。
Alan decided he had to make amends with the crows. A real truce. But how do you do that? How do you make things right with a couple of birds?
Alan决定他必须补偿这些乌鸦。达成真正的休战。但该怎么做呢？你如何与几只鸟重归于好？
If you could have just sat down with them and I could have apologized, and maybe they could have explained why those trees were so important, and I could have shown some understanding for them. And maybe we could have worked things out that way. But because we're unable to do that, I just thought food is maybe the next best thing.
如果我能坐下来和它们道歉，也许它们能解释为什么那些树那么重要，我也能表达我的理解。也许我们可以那样解决问题。但因为我们没法交流，我就觉得食物可能是下一个最好的选择。
Food, you know, the tool of every animal trainer that's ever lived.
食物，你知道，有史以来每一个动物训练师的工具。
And so I found this kind of brass, gold-colored plate. It was shiny. And so I put some almonds on it, and I walked outside with it above my head, kind of, holding my arms straight above my head. And I laid it out on the lawn.
于是我找到了一个铜的、金色的盘子。它很闪亮。我放了一些杏仁在上面，然后举着盘子走出屋子，把胳膊直直地举在头顶上方。我就把它放在草坪上。
The crows caw at him loudly while he puts the plate down. He goes back inside. And a couple hours later, Alan sees the plate sitting there, empty. The almonds are gone.
他放盘子时，乌鸦对着他大声叫。他回到屋里。几个小时后，Alan看到盘子放在那里，是空的。杏仁没了。
I did that for another three days. And then, it was on the fourth day. I came outside with the plate, but they weren't cawing this time. They seemed more subdued, less aggressive. And I put the plate out, I went back inside, and that was the last time I saw them.
我又做了三天。然后，到了第四天。我带着盘子出来时，它们这次没有尖叫。它们显得更温顺了，没那么有攻击性。我把盘子放下，回到屋里，那是我最后一次见到它们。
The crow researcher told me that it seemed like, since Alan had merely stressed the crows out and not actually hurt them, it might have been easier for them to forget why they were mad at him in the first place. Alan said the whole thing, having a couple of birds angry at him-- it kind of hurt his feelings.
乌鸦研究员告诉我，似乎因为Alan仅仅是让乌鸦感到压力，并没有真正伤害它们，它们可能更容易忘记当初为什么要生他的气。Alan说整件事，被几只鸟生他的气——伤害了他的感情。
It's not like he's naive. He knows nature doesn't care about his feelings. It's just that he loves nature so much, and his intentions were good. He can't help but feel like it would have been nice if the crows had shown a little tenderness towards him.
他并不是天真。他知道大自然不在乎他的感受。只是他太热爱自然了，而且他的本意是好的。他不禁觉得，如果乌鸦能对他表现出一点温柔，那该多好。
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer of our program.
Aviva DeKornfeld是我们节目的制作人。
Act Three, You'll Spank Me Later For This. So in the show today about tenderness, we turn now to comedian Josh Johnson, who's been thinking a lot lately about when tenderness is called for, and when the opposite of tenderness may actually be the right way to go.
第三幕，《你以后会因为这个打我》。在今天关于温柔的节目中，我们要转而介绍喜剧演员Josh Johnson，他最近一直在思考何时需要温柔，以及何时温柔的反面可能才是正确的方法。
OK. This is like-- this is, like, a contentious thing. So just stick with me for a second. Because it's weird-- it's weird that people are weird about it. OK. So my friends are having kids, right? A lot of them are starting to have kids, so they're all having the conversation about if they're going to spank their kids, right?
好的。这是一个——这非常有争议。所以请听我说几秒钟。因为很奇怪——人们对这个问题的反应很奇怪。好的。我的朋友们开始生孩子了，对吧？他们很多人开始有孩子了，所以他们都在讨论是否要打孩子，对吧？
And people have very strong feelings either way. Some people think, like, oh, if it's rare and it's warranted, then a spanking here and there is not that bad. And then, some people are like, no, this is, like-- this is full-on abuse. This is, like, you're creating trauma and everything. And I'm not even telling anybody how to feel. Like, I know that I was spanked when I was a kid. And it made sense that I was spanked, because we were poor.
人们对此有强烈的不同感受。有些人认为，如果情况罕见且有正当理由，那么偶尔打一打也没那么坏。然后，有些人觉得，不，这完全是——这是彻头彻尾的虐待。你在制造创伤等等。我并不是要告诉任何人该怎么感受。我知道我小时候被打过。而且打我有道理，因为我们很穷。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Do you understand what I mean? There was nothing to take away.
你明白我的意思吗？没有什么东西可以拿走。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know? Like, there was a year that my mom and I shared a bedroom when I was a little kid. What was she going to take away? The floor?
你知道吗？我小时候有一年我和妈妈共用一个卧室。她能拿走什么？地板吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, rest of the month, you float from now on. And if I catch you not floating, that's your ass, all right? Do you see what I mean? Because I was in a-- I was in a very weird position at one point. Because I didn't have much money, but I got a scholarship.
就像，以后这个月你就漂着吧。如果我抓到你没在漂，那你就完蛋了，好吗？你明白我的意思吗？因为我曾经处于一个非常奇怪的境地。我没什么钱，但我拿到了奖学金。
And my family pooled their money together to make the ends meet for me to go to this Catholic school, right? So I was a kid with no money, going to school with kids with real money. Like, money where they don't need to read.
我的家人凑钱让我去这所天主教学校，对吧？所以我就像个没钱的孩子，去和真正有钱的孩子上学。那种钱多到不需要阅读的程度。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know what I'm talking about? You know that proper money that you can't mess up? You know that old money? And so I remember, there was one time we were-- we were sitting around the lunch table. And, uh-- and this one kid-- yeah, I said something about my mom spanking me for something, and we were still in junior high or whatever. So I was talking about a time from before, you know. And then, this other kid was like, oh, don't worry about it. My dad still spanks me, right? And I was like, ooh. Um.
你知道我在说什么吗？你知道那种你搞不砸的正经钱吗？那种老钱？我记得有一次我们坐在午餐桌旁。然后，呃——这个孩子——我说了关于我妈妈因为某事打我的事，我们还在初中什么的。所以我谈论的是过去的事情。然后，这另一个孩子说，哦，别担心。我爸爸还在打我呢，对吧？我当时心想，噢。嗯。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Tyler, you have a pool. That's abuse.
Tyler，你有游泳池。那是虐待。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I feel like, no matter your-- no matter your feelings on spanking, we've all met-- we've all met, like, a grown man that deserved to have their ass beat.
我觉得，无论你对打屁股有什么感觉，我们都见过——我们都见过一个成年男人该被打屁股。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I think the thing for me-- the thing for me is that when-- could it have happened earlier?
而且我觉得对我来说——对我来说，难道不能早点发生吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I want to be clear here. I'm not, like, blanketing, cosigning anything. I'm asking questions, genuinely. I'm asking questions, because people are very split on it. You know what I mean? But once again, we've all met a dude who, like-- damn.
我想明确一点。我不是在宽恕或认可任何事情。我只是真心在提问。我提问是因为人们对此分歧很大。你明白我的意思吗？但再一次，我们都见过一个家伙，像——该死。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He really probably had it coming sooner than today.
他可能早就该挨这顿打了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But then, how do you-- how do you gauge that, you know? Because I get what some people are saying. Some people are like, look, we're all individuals. So even though you have your kids and your kids have a part of you in them, they're still going to be different people. So then, how do you make sure that this kid doesn't walk away with the worst lesson possible, the worst feeling possible from this thing that worked out for you, but it might not work out for them? That's a scary thing. You know?
但你该怎么衡量呢，你知道吗？因为我明白有些人说的话。有些人说，看，我们都是独立的个体。所以即使你有孩子，孩子身上有你的一部分，他们仍然会是不同的人。那么你该如何确保这个孩子不会从这个对你有效但对他们可能无效的事情中得到最糟糕的教训、最糟糕的感受呢？那是一件可怕的事情。你知道吗？
Like-- OK. I used to-- I used to be, like, very nervous about moving to New York, right? I moved to New York years ago. And I remember when I got to Brooklyn, I saw a fight when I got there. And it was a-- these were two, kind of, big guys. One guy was, like, medium-sized, bigger than me, and he was muscular. And he looked like he knew how to fight, because he did all the stances.
比如——好的。我过去——我过去在搬到纽约时很紧张，对吧？我是几年前搬到纽约的。我记得我到布鲁克林时，看到了一场打架。有两个大个子。一个家伙——中等体型，比我大，很强壮。他看起来像知道怎么打架，因为他摆出了所有姿势。
He knew where to put his shoulders, put his fists. He could kick. He's either trained MMA in boxing, or he's watched all the movies. Like, this guy-- this guy really knows how to move, right? And then, the big guy was just a big guy. Like, he was-- he was that-- you know that type of big where you can't tell if it's fat or muscle? You just know it's in the way. Right? You know he can move things where he wants them to go. Just a big guy. Right? And I don't know-- I don't know exactly what they were fighting about, but it felt like one of those fights. It felt like one of those fights where they really wanted to fight their dad.
他知道肩膀放在哪，拳头放在哪。他会踢腿。他要么受过综合格斗和拳击训练，要么看了所有电影。这个家伙——这家伙真的很懂怎么动，对吧？然后，那个大个子就是个大个子。就像——你知道那种无法分辨是胖还是肌肉的体型吗？你只知道它挡在路上。对吧？你知道他能把东西移到他想放的地方。只是个大个子。对吧？我不知道——我不知道他们到底为了什么打架，但感觉像是那些架之一。感觉像是他们真的很想打他们爸爸。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Have you ever been-- OK, have you ever been in a bar, and then you see a fight brew-- you can smell it brewing. And then you're also like, I think if you had, like, punched your dad years ago, none of this would be happening right now. Like, if you had just had one good row with him, this would be a quiet evening, right?
你有没有——好的，你有没有在酒吧里，看到架势正在酝酿——你能闻到它在酝酿。然后你也会想，我觉得如果你几年前打了你爸爸，现在这一切都不会发生了。就像，如果你和他吵过一架，现在会是个安静的夜晚，对吧？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And, uh, they were going at each other. And some of it was punching. Some of it was kicking. Now, the guy that was, like, on the bigger side and muscular-- he really knew his way around. Like, he was even doing the hop of someone who knows how to fight. You know that little light-foot hop where you're like, they're about to get into it. OK. And then, there was one moment-- because I walked out of this bar, because I was doing a show, like a bar show with my friends, and then we were all walking out. And we all saw this, like, happening.
他们在那互相攻击。有一些是拳击。有一些是踢腿。现在，那个大块头且肌肉发达的家伙——他真的很懂行。他甚至摆出了懂打架人的那种弹跳。你知道那种轻盈的弹跳吗，当你是的时候，他们快要动真格了。好的。然后，有一个瞬间——因为我走出了这个酒吧，因为我在做演出，和我朋友们的一个酒吧演出，然后我们都走出来。我们都看到这事正在发生。
It would start on the sidewalk, and it spilled into the street. And basically, he's doing the hops, and he goes for a lunge. He goes for, like, this big punch, right? And when he goes for the big punch, the big dude moves out of the way and grabs his wrist. And they both look at it. They both look at it like-- he grabs his wrist and looks at it. And then he looks at it like, uh-oh. And--
它开始在人行道上，然后蔓延到了街上。基本上，他在弹跳，然后他准备冲刺。他准备打出重拳，对吧？当他冲过去准备重拳时，那个大块头移开了身子，抓住了他的手腕。他们两个都看着它。他们都看着它像——他抓住他的手腕看着它。然后他看着它像，呃哦。然后——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then-- and then, he grabs his wrist, and with his other hand, he grabs the back of the dude's belt. Right? Pulls him forward, knocks the guy, pretty much, off balance, lets go of the wrist, passes the belt to his other hand, lifts him up, and then-- spanked him in public. And like--
然后——然后，他抓住他的手腕，用另一只手抓住那家伙的腰带。对吧？把他拽向前面，基本上让那家伙失去平衡，放开手腕，把腰带换到另一只手，把他提起来，然后——当众打他屁股。而且就像——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I had never seen somebody with a beard get spanked before. Like--
我从未见过有人带胡子还被打屁股。就像——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he's really, like, floating and everything. And this guy is like, letting him have it, right? Like, one after the other. This dude spanked him so much, he took a break. There was one point where he was holding him suspended in the air by his belt, but also like-- whew.
他真的在飘着什么的。然后这哥们在让他接受惩罚，对吧？一个接一个。这哥们打了他屁股那么多次，他还休息了一下。有一次他用腰带把他悬在半空中，但也像——呼。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then, after, like, the 36th lick, lets go to the belt. Dude drops to the ground. He gets up, and he sort of limps off. A lot of expletives and stuff, but it's kind of done. And this guy goes back into the bar we were just in. Because he wasn't watching the show. The show was in, like, a back room. This guy was just in the bar. And I had no idea, like, what the fight was about. Because, once again, we had already walked out, and it was already happening. But he walked back in, and I'm like-- I'm a curious duck. You know what I mean? Like--
然后，在第36次拍打后，放开腰带。那家伙掉到地上。他站起来，一瘸一拐地走开了。很多脏话什么的，但基本结束了。而这哥们回到了我们刚刚所在的酒吧。因为他没看演出。演出在后面的房间。这哥们就在酒吧里。我根本不知道他们在打什么架。因为，再说一次，我们已经走出来了，而且这事已经在发生了。但他走回去了，而我——我是个好奇的小鸭子。你明白我的意思吗？就像——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I go back in after him, and I'm like, hey, man, are you OK? Which is a weird thing to ask him. But-- it's like, are you OK? What was all that about? And then, he turns to me and goes-- I look like a lot of dudes' dads.
所以我跟着他进去，我说，嘿，伙计，你没事吧？这问他很奇怪。但——就像，你没事吧？那是什么回事？然后他转身对我说——我看起来像很多人的爸爸。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This dude was, like, 30. And he-- and he looked like he could be a dad, right? And so he's like, no, I just look like a lot of dudes' dads. And I was like, wow, how did you find that out? And he was like, oh, yeah. You know, after the fourth or fifth fight--
这哥们大约30岁。他——他看起来确实像个爸爸，对吧？所以他说，不，我只是看起来像很多人的爸爸。我说，哇，你是怎么发现的？他说，哦，是的。你知道，在第四或第五次打架后——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--you just start to put things together.
——你就会把事情拼凑起来。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he told me. He told me that sometimes he goes to the bar with his friends. And he's like, after a while, I can just tell, some guy starts looking at me. And then, he comes, and he starts jawing at me. And I can tell it's not about me, because it's-- I was just sitting here. I wasn't doing anything. And then he wants to fight. And he either swings at me first or he says, let's go outside. But this happens pretty often.
他告诉我。他告诉我有时他会和朋友去酒吧。他说，过了一会儿，我一眼就能看出来，有些家伙开始盯着我。然后他走过来，开始跟我叫板。我知道那不是关于我，因为它是——我就坐在这。我什么也没做。然后他想打架。他要么先朝我挥拳，要么说，我们出去。但这经常发生。
And I was like, wow, are you a dad, though? And he was like, yeah.
我说，哇，你真的是爸爸吗？他说，是啊。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was like, do you spank your kid?
我说，你会打你孩子屁股吗？
He was like, oh, no. No, I would never.
他说，哦，不。不，我绝不会。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Josh Johnson. Check out his YouTube channel, Josh Johnson Comedy. Tour dates, videos, and albums are at joshjohnsoncomedy.com.
Josh Johnson。去看看他的YouTube频道Josh Johnson Comedy。巡演日期、视频和专辑都在joshjohnsoncomedy.com。
Act Four, The Feels on the Bus. There are, of course, so many people who believe that being tenderhearted is not a good way to live in this tough and unforgiving world. For some people, it's a matter of principle. They think it works out better for everybody that way. Etgar Keret has this short story about someone like that.
第四幕，《公交车上的情感》。当然，有很多人认为有一颗柔软的心并不是在这个艰难且无情的世界上生存的好方法。对一些人来说，这是一个原则问题。他们认为那样对每个人都更好。Etgar Keret有一个关于这样的人的短篇小说。
This is a story about a bus driver who would never open the door of the bus for people who were late. Not for anyone. Not for repressed high school kids who'd run alongside the bus and stare at it longingly, and not for high-strung people in windbreakers who'd bang on the door as if they were actually on time, and it was the driver who was out of line.
这是一个关于公交车司机的故事，他从不为迟到的人打开公交车门。对谁都不。对那些跟着公交车跑、渴望地盯着它的压抑高中生，不对；对那些穿风衣、仿佛他们真的没迟到、是司机的问题而敲门的紧张人士，不对。
And not even for little old ladies with brown paper bags full of groceries, who struggled to flag him down with trembling hands. And it wasn't because he was mean that he didn't open the door. Because this driver didn't have a mean bone in his body. It was a matter of ideology.
即使是对提着装满食品杂货的棕色纸袋、挣扎着挥动颤抖的手想拦下他的老太太也不行。他不开门并不是因为他刻薄。因为这个司机身上根本没有刻薄的骨头。这是一个意识形态问题。
The driver's ideology said that even if the delay caused by opening the door for someone who came late, was just under 30 seconds, and even if not opening the door meant that this person would wind up losing 15 minutes of his life, it would still be more fair to society to not open the door. Because the seconds would be lost by every single passenger on the bus. And if there were, say, 60 people on the bus who hadn't done anything wrong and had all arrived to the bus stop on time, then together, they'd be losing half an hour, which is double 15 minutes.
司机的意识形态说，即使为迟到的人开门造成的延误只有不到30秒，即使不开门意味着这个人会损失15分钟的生命，不对人开门对社会依然更公平。因为这些秒数是车上每一位乘客损失的。如果有，比如说，车上有60个没做错什么而且都准时到达车站的人，那么加起来，他们会损失半个小时，是15分钟的两倍。
This was the only reason why he never opened the door. He knew that the passengers hadn't the slightest idea what his reason was, and that the people running after the bus and signaling him to stop had no idea either. He also knew that most of them thought he was just an ass [BLEEP], and that personally, it would have been much, much easier for him to let them on and receive their smiles and thanks. Except that when it came to choosing between smiles and thanks on the one hand and the good of society on the other, this driver knew what it had to be.
这就是他从不开门的唯一原因。他知道乘客们一点都不知道他的理由是什么，那些追着公交车、示意他停车的人也不知道。他也知道他们中大多数人认为他只是个混蛋，而且个人而言，如果让他们上车并收到他们的微笑和感谢，对他来说会容易得多。只是当需要在微笑、感谢和社会利益之间做选择时，这个司机知道该怎么选。
The person who should have suffered the most from the driver's ideology was named Eddie. But unlike the other people in this story, he wouldn't even try to run for the bus. That's how lazy and out of it he was.
本来应该在这个司机的意识形态中遭受损失最大的人叫Eddie。但不同于这个故事中的其他人，他甚至不会试着跑去追公交车。他就是那么懒，那么不在状态。
Now, Eddie was assistant cook at a restaurant called The Steakout, which was the best pun that the stupid owner of this place could come up with. The food there was nothing to write home about.
现在，Eddie是一家叫“The Steakout”的餐厅的副厨师，这是那个愚蠢的老板能想出的最好的双关语。那里的食物实在是不敢恭维。
But Eddie himself was a really nice guy. So nice, that sometimes when something he made didn't come out too great, he'd serve it to the table himself and apologize. It was during one of these apologies that he met happiness, or at least a shot at happiness, in the form of a girl that was so sweet that she tried to finish the entire portion of roast beef he brought her, just so he wouldn't feel bad.
但Eddie本人是个非常好的人。好到有时他做的一些菜做得不太好，他会自己端到桌前道歉。就在其中一次道歉中，他遇到了幸福，或者说至少是一次得到幸福的机会，形式是一个女孩，她太甜了，为了不让他感到难过，她试图吃完他端给她的整份烤牛肉。
And this girl didn't want to tell him her name or give him her phone number. But she was sweet enough to agree to meet him the next day at 5:00 at a spot they decided on together. The Dolphinarium, to be exact.
这个女孩不想告诉他她的名字，也不想给他电话号码。但她甜到同意第二天5点在他们商定的地方见他。确切地说，是海豚馆。
Now, Eddie had this condition, one that had already caused him to miss out on all sorts of things in life. It wasn't one of those conditions where your adenoids get all swollen or anything like that. But still, it had already caused him a lot of damage.
现在，Eddie有这种毛病，这种毛病已经让他错过了生活中各种各样的事情。它不是那种腺样体肿大什么的毛病。但依然，它已经给他造成了很多伤害。
This sickness always made him oversleep by 10 minutes, and no alarm clock did any good. That was why he was always late for work at The Steakout. That, and our bus driver, the one who always chose the good of society over smiles and thanks.
这种病总是让他睡过头10分钟，什么闹钟都没用。这就是他为什么总是上班迟到。那个原因，加上我们的公交车司机，总是选择社会利益而不是微笑和感谢的那位。
Except that this time, since happiness was at stake, Eddie decided to beat the condition. And instead of taking an afternoon nap, he stayed awake and watched television. Just to be on the safe side, he even lined up, not one, but three alarm clocks, and ordered the wakeup call to boot. But this sickness was incurable, and Eddie fell asleep like a baby, watching the kiddy channel.
只不过这次，因为幸福危在旦夕，Eddie决定战胜这个毛病。他没有午睡，而是保持清醒看电视。为了保险起见，他甚至排成一排，不止是一个，而是三个闹钟，还预约了叫醒电话。但这病是绝症，Eddie像个婴儿一样睡着了，看着儿童频道。
He woke up in a sweat to the screeching of a trillion, million alarm clocks. 10 minutes too late. Rushed out of the house without stopping to change and ran toward the bus stop. He barely remembered how to run anymore, and his feet fumbled a bit every time they left the sidewalk.
他在一万亿个闹钟的尖叫声中惊醒。迟了10分钟。冲出房子，没来得及换衣服就向公交车站跑去。他几乎不记得怎么跑步了，每次离开人行道他的脚都会踉跄一下。
The last time he ran was before he discovered he could cut gym class, which was about in the sixth grade. Except that unlike in those gym classes, this time, he ran like crazy. Because now, he had something to lose.
他上次跑步是在他发现可以逃掉体育课之前，大概是在六年级。只不过不同于那些体育课，这次他疯狂地跑。因为现在，他有东西可输。
And all the pain in his chest and his Lucky Strike wheezing weren't going to get in the way of his pursuit of happiness. Nothing was going to get in his way. Except our bus driver, who had just closed the door and was beginning to pull away.
胸部的剧痛和Lucky Strike烟带来的喘鸣无法阻挡他对幸福的追求。没有什么能阻挡他。除了我们的公交车司机，他刚刚关上门，开始驶离。
The driver saw Eddie in the rearview mirror. But as we've already explained, he had an ideology that, more than anything, relied on love of justice and on simple arithmetic. Except that Eddie didn't care about the driver's arithmetic. For the first time in his life, he really wanted to get somewhere on time. And that's why he went right on chasing the bus, even though he didn't have a chance.
司机在后视镜里看到了Eddie。但正如我们已经解释过的，他有一个意识形态，比起其他任何东西，更依赖于对正义的爱和简单的算术。只不过Eddie不在乎司机的算术。这是他一生中第一次真正想准时到达某个地方。这就是为什么他继续追着公交车，尽管他没什么机会。
But then, Eddie's luck turned. But only halfway. 100 yards past the bus stop, there was a traffic light. And just a second before the bus reached it, the traffic light turned red.
但随后，Eddie的运气转了。但只转了一半。离公交车站100码的地方有一个交通灯。就在公交车到达的前一秒，交通灯变红了。
Eddie managed to catch up with the bus and to drag himself all the way to the driver's door. He didn't even bang on the glass, he was so weak. He just looked at the driver with moist eyes and fell to his knees, panting and wheezing.
Eddie勉强追上了公交车，拖着身子一直走到司机车门边。他甚至没敲玻璃，他太虚弱了。他只是湿润着眼睛看着司机，瘫跪在地上，喘着气，呼哧作响。
And this reminded the driver of something. Something from out of the past, from a time before he wanted to become a bus driver, when he still wanted to become God. It was kind of a sad memory, because the driver didn't become God at the end. But it was a happy one, too, because he became a bus driver, which was his second choice.
这让司机想起了一些事。过去的一些事，在他想成为公交车司机之前，当他仍然想成为上帝的时候。那是一种悲伤的记忆，因为司机最终没能成为上帝。但这也是一种幸福的记忆，因为他成为了公交车司机，这是他的第二选择。
And suddenly, the driver remembered how he at once promised himself that if he became God in the end, he'd be merciful and kind and would listen to all his creatures. So when he saw Eddie from way up in his driver's seat, kneeling on the asphalt, he simply couldn't go through with it. And in spite of all his ideology and his simple arithmetic, he opened the door, and Eddie got on and didn't even say "thank you," he was so out of breath.
突然，司机想起他曾答应过自己，如果最终成为了上帝，他会仁慈、善良，倾听所有生物的声音。所以当他从高高的驾驶座上看到Eddie，跪在沥青上，他简直无法坚持下去。尽管有他所有的意识形态和简单的算术，他打开了门，Eddie上了车，甚至没说“谢谢”，他实在喘不过气来。
OK. Maybe the best thing would be to stop listening right now. Because even though Eddie did get to the Dolphinarium on time, happiness didn't come. Because happiness already had a boyfriend.
好的。也许最好现在就停止收听。因为尽管Eddie确实准时到了海豚馆，幸福并没有来。因为幸福已经有了男朋友。
It's just that she was so sweet that she couldn't bring herself to tell Eddie, so she preferred to stand him up. Eddie waited for her on the bench they'd agreed on for almost two hours. While he sat there, he kept thinking all sorts of depressing thoughts about his life.
只不过她太甜了，以至于无法忍心告诉Eddie，所以她宁愿放他鸽子。Eddie在他们约定好的长椅上等了她近两个小时。他坐在那儿时，一直在想关于他生活的各种沮丧念头。
And while he was at it, he watched the sunset, which was a pretty good one, and thought about how cramped his legs were going to be later on. When he was really desperate to get home, he saw his bus in the distance, pulling in at the bus stop and letting go of passengers. And he knew that even if he'd had the strength to run, he'd never catch up with it anyway.
与此同时，他看着日落，那是一个相当不错的日落，还想到他的腿之后会有多酸痛。当他真的很渴望回家时，他在远处看到了他的公交车，停在车站让乘客下车。他知道即使他有力气跑，也永远追不上了。
So he just kept on walking slowly, feeling about a million tired muscles with every step. And when he finally reached the bus stop, he saw that the bus was still there, waiting for him. And even though the passengers were shouting and grumbling to get a move on, the driver waited for Eddie, and he didn't touch the accelerator till Eddie was seated. And when they started moving, he looked in the rearview mirror and gave Eddie a sad wink, which somehow made the whole thing almost bearable.
所以他就一直慢慢地走着，每走一步都能感觉到一百万个疲惫的肌肉。当他最终到达公交车站时，他看到公交车还在那儿，等着他。尽管乘客们在叫嚷、抱怨着快点开，司机还是等了Eddie，直到Eddie坐下他才碰加速踏板。当他们开始移动时，他看着后视镜，给了Eddie一个悲伤的眨眼，这莫名其妙地让整件事变得几乎可以忍受。
Etgar Keret, reading the title story from his collection, The Bus Driver Who Wanted to be God, and Other Stories. If you want to get a short story in your email from Etgar once a week, you can sign up for that at his Substack, at [email protected] that's Keret, K-E-R-E-T.
Etgar Keret，阅读他的选集《想要成为上帝的公交车司机及其他故事》中的同名故事。如果你想每周收到Etgar的一封电子邮件短篇小说，你可以在他的Substack上注册，地址是 [email protected] 那是Keret，K-E-R-E-T。
Our program was produced today by Ike Sriskandarajah and Henry Larson. The people who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Angela Gervasi, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由Ike Sriskandarajah和Henry Larson制作。制作今天节目的团队包括Jendayi Bonds, Angela Gervasi, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney和Julie Whitaker。我们的执行主编Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行主编是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to the team at All In on Broadway-- director Alex Timbers, producers Micah Frank and Greg Nobile, also Scott Rowan and Allison Ebling, Wagner Johnson Productions, O&M, and everybody else at the Hudson Theater. Also thanks today to Emily Woodbury and Griffin Dunne.
特别感谢今天百老汇《All In》团队——导演Alex Timbers，制片人Micah Frank和Greg Nobile，还有Scott Rowan和Allison Ebling，Wagner Johnson Productions, O&M，以及哈德森剧院的所有其他人。也感谢今天的Emily Woodbury和Griffin Dunne。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. To become a This American Life Partner, which gets you bonus content, ad-free listening, and hundreds of our favorite episodes of the show that will show up right in your podcast feed, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. It's a great deal. It helps us out. That link is also in the show notes.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。要成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，从而获得奖励内容、无广告收听和数百个我们最喜欢的节目集，这些节目将直接显示在你的播客订阅源中，请访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。这很划算。它能帮我们很大忙。该链接也在节目说明中。
Thanks this week to Life Partners Stacey Dixson, Dan Evans III, Matthew Rahtz, Sarah Reen, Elan Saratovsky, and Joe Thorne.
感谢本周的合作伙伴Stacey Dixson, Dan Evans III, Matthew Rahtz, Sarah Reen, Elan Saratovsky和Joe Thorne。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's been throwing out all of his old CDs, every single one, but he is such a Bono fan. He looks at the package, Joshua Tree, Achtung Baby, and screams--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他一直在扔掉他所有的旧CD，每一张都扔了，但他是个Bono铁杆粉。他看着包装盒，Joshua Tree，Achtung Baby，然后尖叫——
Oh, god! I can't lose you, too!
噢，天呐！我也不能失去你！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。